hi I'm Michael Moynihan for recent TV
and today we are at the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum with Steve
looker - the curator of state of
Deception the power of Nazi propaganda
we wanted to examine the role of Nazi
propaganda how they used it to
facilitate persecution mass murder and
war when you think about how quick that
Nazi rise to power was but for most of
the the period of the Weimar Republic
the Nazi Party was largely a joke 28 the
Nazi Party only had 12 seats in the
German parliament out of almost 600 but
1930 gets a hundred and seven seats 1932
and more than doubles that if they learn
how to simplify a message how to play
upon voters emotions how to reduce very
complicated issues to slow this this is
a Braille copy of minecon Braille copy
of Mein Kampf contemporaneously when
people reading this yeah perfectly those
that were the propagandist this was kind
of the Bible for them that they would
draw on what was said in there and of
course excerpts are mine comfrey used
everywhere to justify various policies
but the this became a best-seller and
Hitler made a fortune off the royalties
from this that was published in I think
16 17 different languages these posters
inform us a great deal about Nazi
thinking and the ways in which they
presented images to the public whether
it's of this kind of strong heroic
figure breaking the chains of slavery
this playing upon dissatisfaction with
the status quo the ways in which they
engaged in what today we would call
niche marketing so it's women who work
in the home farmers workers
and I associate the Nazis with the word
freedom but they used it and Leslie what
was the turn methodology but behind
choosing these bright red colors
Hitler talked about how in the early 20s
he would create posters for his meetings
in red because he understood the way
could provoke people that it was it was
a way to engage an audience to get them
into those beer halls so are they
consciously drawing from from the
Bolshevik example somewhat gurbles
talked about the power of film one of
the films that he always cited was
battleship Oh Jim
[Music]
what's happening now after 1933 1934 the
Nazis saw the importance of controlling
the media this ministry of public
enlightenment and propaganda it was
created as a cabinet-level post for
Joseph Goebbels who also was in charge
of the Nazi party's propaganda apparatus
so in the state this means newsreels
films books radio libraries here we have
the great big political show of National
Socialism the two attacks on Jews but as
both being capitalist and and Bolsheviks
confused and silly but but but
apparently effective so how does one
prepare the the population for this kind
of machinery of destruction there is an
effort made to both present the Jews as
a real physical threat to Germany and
also to identify Jews as being the
powers behind the enemy they would show
these Soviet atrocities against the
local population and then identify the
Jews as the perpetrators of that in this
particular poster dealing with the
discovery of a Soviet crime in vain'
eats us to identify Jewish Bolshevik is
the perpetrator of that crime is this
the original painting yes it is yeah now
the title comes from the New Testament
book of John but instead of having Jesus
as a messianic figure we have our Dolf
Hitler and you can see in the painting
the way the light emanates off Adolf
Hitler's face over the audience the
audience is portrayed as a kind of a
microcosm of German society but it also
emphasizes the importance that Hitler
and the Nazis placed on the spoken-word
that Adolphe Hitler believed that the
spoken word for more than the written
word was responsible for all the great
events in history
it allowed you direct contact with your
audience that is you could play upon
their hopes fears and frustrations you
could get immediate feedback about what
worked and what didn't work and all that
became important as you tailored your
message how do you see this as relevant
to today I mean what does this tell us
about today's political propaganda if
anything an exhibition like this raises
questions about how we address
propaganda is it through restricting
speech or is it more of the American
marketplace of ideas that is the best
way to address what one might consider
offensive speech and also how to
evaluate all the information that were
bombarded with today and how to make
educated informed decisions
[Music]